so we've cut into two Steven and andreas
time by a few minutes and I'm going to
keep my introduction of them quite brief
just to say that the we're going back
into collaboration for the last session
and the collaborations we talked about
earlier our Lord we're largely focused
on collection building and I think now
we're going to be looking at a somewhat
larger and broader goal so I'm vehicles
and Steven am going to be well thank you
Bob so is mentioned Andrea and I are to
be talking about an exploration of new
models or models for national
collaborative work on web archiving
hopefully this won't be too
anti-climactic for you since in
distinction devery all the cool stuff
we've been hearing all day long we're
sort of talking about something that we
haven't actually quite done a whole lot
of yet but but we're hopeful so first
off why are we doing this at all what's
what's what's the need for this
extensive collaboration and cooperation
well I think this is something that all
of you intuitively understand that's
simply that the the problems inherent to
large-scale web archiving are just two
fundamental to significant for any one
organization to try to respond to them
effectively there's any number of
potential problems that we have to deal
with just highlighting to the two that
that tend to come up most often first of
all is the question of web scale
certainly if you are a library that is
interested in starting up a new program
and web archiving you are going to be
faced almost certainly with having to
deal with the corpus that is at least
one to two orders of magnitude larger
than what you've dealt with here to form
secondly there's the sense that we are
continually falling behind in this
ongoing technological arms race we've
heard allusions to this throughout the
day that the the internet and the web
have really undergone this amazing sea
change over the last however many years
from essentially a document retrieval
system to this vast distributed virtual
machine that's running
highly dynamic programs in this regard I
particularly like the example we saw
earlier today of the the scroll bar art
because this reminds us that not only is
it bad enough that content creators are
out exploiting a lot of these new web
capabilities to the fullest extent for
their intended purpose but even beyond
that their RVs and interestingly
creative people who are actively
subverting these capabilities for a
completely different set of probably
completely unanticipated and unintended
purposes so what does this mean a little
bit more concretely from the experience
that we have at the CDL and and at
Harvard at CDL we've been interested in
working in the area of web archiving
since about 2006 we have an early grants
from the LCS and dip initiative we went
live with the production web archiving
service or was in 2008 and since then
this has grown quite significantly we
are now supporting over 40 unique
curatorial units some of these are
exuberant ly unique they have about 280
collections and we're up around 135
terabytes of material early on we made a
decision to rely on what's becoming a
fairly standard open-source stack Hera
tricks nuts wax open way back and we
thought oh great we don't have to do any
work well that turned out not to be true
even with the amazing powers of these
open source components you still need to
have a lot of infrastructural glue to
make these things cooperate and to
implement effective workflows we also
found that we had to develop locally a
complete curatorial interface that could
be used for defining seeds applying
descriptive metadata crawling skulls
crawl scopes and so forth
all of this is running on a fairly large
infrastructure elite prints we have 11
servers big servers actually there's
about 100 terabytes of locally attached
staging space over 150 terabytes of San
that's used for both archival and access
purposes from the beginning was has
always operated on a fee-for-service
basis for within the UC community we're
out charging our customers only for the
amount of space that they're consuming
for external customers there's an
additional service fee so with this
revenue that was coming in we were able
to somewhat dedicate about two and a
half FTE to this project and to this
product unfortunately what we found over
these last seven or eight years is two
and a half FTE is just about necessary
just about sufficient for dealing with
just our necessary operational demands
there has been very little time and
resources left over for all sorts of
other necessary maintenance and
improvements so for example we are we've
fallen very far behind in terms of
software upgrades we're still running
here tricks one rather than heretics
three we've never had the time to
complete a replacement of notch with
solar we've never had time to implement
deduplication so quite a bit of
technical debt that has that is built up
there so in sort of trying to summarize
this whole experience I would say a
little bit of hyperbole but that even
though we're running on a
fee-for-service basis the only way we
were going to be able to make this a
truly sustainable service is we either
had to get a whole lot larger or we had
to get a whole lot smaller getting
larger just did not seem to be very
tractable situation and getting smaller
just was not particularly attractive so
we felt it is very much necessary for us
to find a different way of operating
and that almost surely involves getting
involved with the number of partners
that we can help to share out the load
so let me step aside and hear about
Harvard we've had a kind of a similar
situation at Harvard with web archiving
we started talking to our curators i
think around 2006 asking them because we
had you know we had been doing digitized
collections for a long time and we
wanted to find out what what matters to
you in the born digital realm what do
you want to start collecting and
preserving first and the answer was web
archives or websites and so we we
started working on and putting together
a service for web archiving and were
able to put it into production in 2009
the original partners that we worked
with three curatorial units at Harvard
sussing or library the Harvard
University Archives and the rush hour
center where our original pilot partners
that helped us develop the functional
requirements and collect it and test it
like like was from CDL it used what we
thought you know were the obvious tools
to use Harrow tricks way back networks
and something that's not supported
anymore called the HCC which is it's
kind of a controller for crawlers which
actually still runs really well for us
but nobody's nobody's maintaining it and
a variety of different open source tools
some custom Java models which are
basically the glue to make it all work
and a custom curatorial interface we
were happy at the time you know in 2009
em it was it was basically a
self-service some model where the
curators could go into the interface and
they could come up with you know how
often this thing should be crawled which
of our standard scoping scopes should
this follow etc and it would just kind
of work the whole system would work and
there was a way there is a way to
automatically push it to our
preservation repository which we were
happy about so we you know we were ready
to celebrate and then all of a sudden
the kind of the rug pulled out from
under us
because all of a sudden okay the library
is reorganizing in 2009 so it was a
really bad timing for us because we were
just about to say okay what should be
the operating cost model should this you
know for this thing which should be the
dedicated staff for this thing how
should we expand this to more curatorial
units so long story short during that
reorganization which actually I count as
four different reorganizations within
that time period because it really was
our system stagnated and like CDL saw we
had we now have years of technical debt
we had nobody dedicated to this you know
not from the service provider
perspective or from the developers
perspective and none of that software
has been upgraded during this time and
so hair tricks is now several versions
ahead we're also still using networks
instead of solar and we're still using
arc instead of work and it's still only
being used by the original three
curatorial units so we looked at this
and we thought okay if we were to bring
bring this up up to speed you know
modernize it scale it up really put it
into you know production if we think it
would take 2.5 FTE for one year to
upgrade it and that includes some
development staff but also some support
staff some liaison to the curators and
then 3ft on an ongoing basis and around
two FTE is closer to what the library
wants to to put onto this at the moment
but I'm looking at this and you know
whether you say to FD III FTE it's kind
of really the same it's not that much of
a difference but the real the real issue
is what are you going to spend your
development resources on so you have a
certain amount of development resources
are you going to spend it working on on
maintaining crawlers you know working on
always expanding your full text index
that kind of just kind of stuff that
should already be there or are you going
to spend it on kind of the more
interesting things like the supporting
new
search supporting new ways of acquiring
content supporting you no more modern
interfaces which wouldn't be silos of
just web harvests you know browsing
through that but it would integrate
different types of content and from
different institutions you know that
kind of more interesting work so that's
really the issue for us it is how can we
transition to something that is in
collaboration with a lot of other people
and and makes it so that we can spend
our developer resources on those things
that we can't find elsewhere so I think
there's also been a number of allusions
to the potential benefits of
collaboration throughout the day and
these three particular points we saw
actually up on the screen this morning
these are three areas in which the I IPC
has identified partly as a justification
for its own existence but I think it's
pretty clear that basically everything
that they're saying here in an
international context would apply
equally well within the US or some other
national context we just feel certainly
based on our collective experience as
well as some others of you that we're
partnering with and we've had we've had
conversations with that collaboration is
just the best and the fastest way to
build up the largest body of Internet
content it's the fastest and the best
way to develop maintain and enhance the
tool set that's necessary to build up
that collection and it's the the best
way to encourage and engage in outreach
regarding issues surrounding web
archiving so the discussions around how
to how to sort of make this happen have
been going on now for a number of years
one of the earliest activities was the
cool hosted events that unfortunately I
did not attend so I'm going to let
Andrea summarize well many of you I
think did attend this and I think what
stood out for me attending this meeting
roughly three years ago was that it was
the first time that that I had seen a
group of US based institutions who are
involved in web archiving or are
interested in becoming involved in web
archiving get together and it wasn't
based we weren't all I IPC members we
weren't all archived at users we weren't
didn't have any sort of organizational
affiliation and any other way other than
we were all trying to put together web
archiving programs and figure it out and
the topics were very similar today I
mean it was about tools it was also
about collaboration but I think it was
kind of in an important meeting and
started the conversations of how can we
in the u.s. leverage our you know we're
all trying to do this kind of thing how
can we work together
so then help well smack about a year ago
now as we became more and more convinced
that we needed to find collaborative
partners we started having some
one-on-one conversations with peer
institutions certainly Harvard Stanford
our colleagues at UCLA and other places
and it we quickly thought that it would
be useful to actually convene a
face-to-face summit which happened in
June of last year these are the the
people who were able to attend and it
was very it was very useful in good
meeting the fairly complete notes are
available and that Google Doc but i
think most importantly as is mentioned
here in this one little quote that there
was complete agreement that as we say
here more robust collaboration was
desirable in order to collectively
address the challenges that all of these
individual institutions were facing so
of course while there's always great
enthusiasm for things in the abstract
there's the more difficult question of
you know what can we do sort of
concretely to achieve these highly
desirable goals so one of the follow-up
activities from that meeting was
development of this document available
here what we're calling community
principles for web archiving its scale
and it's fairly short documents it
started to just sketch out the the
overall structure of what we're calling
a lightweight structure by which web
archiving institutions can work together
collaboratively one of the key steps
that was identified in this document is
the first of all based on the
recognition that there are at least
three important operating modes for web
archiving activities that we want to
facilitate and nurture there are certain
things that may want to happen most
efficiently on a centralized manner
there are things that want to be
distributed but coordinated and then
there are probably want to be things
that are always going to be highly
customized for local needs and purposes
so from a technical point of view we
think what's what's really necessary
here is to define a comprehensive set of
AP is that can expose the full range of
web archiving function sort of at these
critical junctures in nominal workflows
this is important we think for making
the possibility of adhering to to this
very high level principle of trying to
rely on community solutions whenever
they are available and only fall back to
customized solutions whenever necessary
and particularly whenever you think that
you can uniquely add value so with that
in mind we would get sort of an
infrastructural picture that looks
something like this you probably can't
see that at all basically the the purple
the purple boxes represent high level
activities in sort of a nominal workflow
so if we work I'm not a technology guy
if you work your way down from from the
top to the bottom we're sort of starting
out with you know curatorial in a
curatorial management where you would be
defining seeds defining cross scope
adding curatorial description then
moving down through capture both in
terms of traditional web crawling as
well as our alternative capture
mechanisms storage indexing for for
future discovery search replay and then
down towards the bottom a new set of
evolving computational tools some of
which we just saw a little bit earlier
this afternoon the now any or all of
those activities you could decide to
outsource to some sort of a service
provider such as archive it that's what
we're representing on that left-hand
side what we're calling
sort of common core or any or all of
those you may want to hold on to more
tightly and run those as local
activities we're sort of showing that on
the on the right hand side and then
because what we're very much interested
in is to allow the free definition of
hybrid workflows where you have an
appetizer from column 1 and the entrees
from column 2 we are interposing those
green boxes which represent them a whole
series of AP is at the interface between
those those large workflow items and
these api's can be exploited both for
injecting information into or extracting
information out of any particular
instantiation of a web archiving
infrastructure that would would
implement those api's so there's been
some follow-up work that is trying to
take that picture and turn that into an
actuality and again I'll let em do Tom
some of it so this looked to us like the
start of a national digital platform
which I MLS is very much interested in
and so we decided to put a grant in the
national leadership grant for libraries
and the way they do it now for those
particular grants is first you put in a
preliminary proposal and then you can be
invited to put in a full proposal so we
decided to go for the the one earlier
this year and invited a number of
institutions to Boston in January to
help us put together a grant and for
some reason a lot of them said okay and
came to Boston and but that was before
all the snow in February's it was okay
and helped us put together this
preliminary proposal which we submitted
and there were three strands of
activities in this proposal the first
was an environment environmental scan
what are our common challenges what are
yous cases what are the functional
requirements and then there were two
types of collaboration developing these
collaborations one was from an
organizational standpoint and the other
from a technical standpoint so from the
technical standpoint you know okay does
that model make sense with the api's
Kent can we prototype some of them can
we test some of them and can we show
that they really are plug and play and
they can work with different components
from the organizational standpoint if
you're going to put your you know your
web archiving program into this kind of
collaboration you want to make sure that
this collaboration is going to last it's
sustainable it has funds it has
commitment that it's it's kind of a
collaboration that can support
activities from smaller institutions as
well as larger institutions that
everybody has a way to participate and
to put something into that collaboration
so there were those three strands of
activity we were not invited to submit
the full proposal which was unfortunate
but we have talks since then and are
want to submit it again in another
probably IMLS grant round in the
meantime we have a couple different sets
of activities going on to prepare better
you know based on the what we got back
from the reviewers from that grant and
one is doing some work with the IPC
because they have some of the same
obviously interests and challenges as we
do and you can learn about some of this
by and there was a recent deal i
magazine article that you can look at
and it was written by some of us in the
preservation working group within the
IPC and in the in this article it talks
about what is the current state of
digital preservation for web archiving
for I IPC members and it's something
that does not get a lot of attention
normally I mean even today if you think
about the different topics we heard it's
a lot of it is still about collecting
you know you know it's good that a lot
of it now is about use of web archives
but we're still not quite having a lot
of conversations about the preservation
of web archives and so we did run a
survey for the I MPC members and you can
learn some of the results if you read
that article it's
but it's not looking very great I'll
tell you that I'll give you one example
which just really stands in my mind was
kind of disturbing a little bit and so
we asked about different preservation
practices and you know do you do this
for your web archives do you do this we
asked about replication which is a
really basic thing everybody knows you
need to have more than one copyright of
something if you want to hope to keep
this thing and roughly fifty percent a
little under fifty percent we're not
even doing replication for their web
archives and you know it's
understandable because a lot of these
institutions are collecting a lot of
material you know at the domain level
but still you know if you're going to
continue to put a lot of effort and
funding into this you want to make sure
that you can hold on to this so there's
clearly a lot of work that needs to go
on in the preservation arena and the
article goes on to talk about over the
years what we've done in the
preservation working group to it to
address our challenges and it's always
been around sharing tools and practices
and that kind of thing so there is a lot
of precedent to having this kind of you
know this is kind of technical solutions
being one part of the solution for
helping us with our challenges and
recently at the I IPC General Assembly
at Stanford there were several
presentations that talked about the need
for api's is this very same thing that
we had been working on because everybody
is concerned about maintaining these
infrastructures over time and being able
to meet new researcher expectations and
so you know wanting to have these
maintainable infrastructure's where you
can say okay this Q a tool is now better
i'm going to try to switch over to that
or this research or tool looks great i'm
just going to plug it into my system but
you can't do that kind of thing unless
you do have this common API
infrastructure kind of thing so since
there was a lot of interests at the
within the IPC we put out a survey to
see if there would be interested in
pursuing doing some work in this area
and it's the survey is still open but
we've heard from 18 different
institutions so far and one hundred
percent of them are
interested in this idea of a pis and
it's now yeah i think it is still
ninety-four percent are willing to
participate in a new my pc working group
to work on this area to develop the use
cases the functional requirements even
the prototype the technical
specifications for an api so how does
that relate to what we were talking
about it from the national perspective
well maybe we ought to talk about the
international context i don't i don't
know but at the very least what we can
do is take the use cases the functional
requirements the technical
specifications that we get from this I a
pc working group and combine them with
parallel efforts that will have to do
here in the US because we know you know
not all of us involved in webinar
driving are in the I IPC and we do have
some special requirements that do need
to get to be fed into this national
digital platform so wrapping up I hope
what we've been able to show you is that
there and this is obvious to you all
because that you know this too there's
widespread recognition of the benefits
of collaborative approaches we heard
earlier what was the phrase radical
collaboration and I think that you know
there's a lot of us in favor of that a
lot of interest in api's and willingness
to work together on this which is great
and that we are continuing to look for
funding opportunities to facilitate this
effort and so if you have ideas for how
to advance this we be very interested in
that as well thank
so there any hot pervert
thanks in your architectural diagram
there I couldn't help but noticing
display API and I kinda was wondering
what kind of requirements do you have
there that go beyond what the memento
protocol gives which is better than an
API to n RFC and it's already supported
by open way back and a lot of other
systems yeah we don't really have any
tangible requirements at this point we
have a diagram so part of the
environmental scan one part of it will
be seeing what are the existing guys
what are the existing things we can use
this obviously we don't want to create
something where there's already
something we can use yes front here
um yeah so my background from coming
from a very small arts nonprofit and
having to think about participating in
collaborative web archiving affords and
seeing this diagram is of course kind of
intimidating and what what we managed to
do is also because we I think we made
some quite good progress with with web
archiving for ourselves and have been
doing since 1996 but we haven't for
example approached things at web scale
and I I wonder this is such a thing that
seems totally undisputed here that
everything has to be at an astronomic
scale and I wonder if you want to get
more input into into this field you you
should think about small institutions
that don't even have the I don't know
that that will never be able to put even
half of this work into work what you
have on this diagram but it is more like
the experimentation and the and also
interesting input just i think is very
much located in small institutions but
yeah if you need to be I don't know a
paying member of several organizations
also even to participate I'm so happy to
be invited here by the way yeah that's
that's great and you know how to do that
but yeah I think this is this is a big
thing because small institutions they
can give the depth instead of the breath
and for example using the memento
protocol it can still be a universal
kind of web archiving afford without ya
how many API is I would need to
implement here to even take part in this
party I think that's that's yeah just
just how I see the world yeah no I think
that's a that's a very fair point the
the most of the issues and the results
that we've been talking about here
reflect the needs of the organizations
that are participating in this
activities and which we did tend to be
more on the larger side here CDL where
we're supporting you know ten campuses
you know lots of curators lot of
collections and so forth the picture
itself yet could be seen as being
intimidating but again the point here is
not that any any one organization would
be responsible for implementing
everything on there it's what we're
trying to get across here is that you
could pick and choose you know I want to
yeah
okay I don't want to answer that
question by channeling Jimmy yeah I dont
still hear that the point about so what
we're facing is a situation where most
of the tools that we use currently come
from a system architecture background
that's now obsolete and what Jimmy was
showing is that by using the system
architectures that been developed for
web scale systems outside preservation
we can build systems that actually scale
down to a Raspberry Pi and the piece
that that Jimmy didn't mention is
something that we talked about at the I
OPC GA which is also that there are now
extremely good tools for delivering
pre-configured Assemblies of complex web
scale systems such as docker and so on
that can be used by people who are
putting them together to deliver these
things to people in a plug-and-play
fashion I think what we're really facing
is is actually not so much the need to
define complex new architectures but
simply to rebuild our infrastructure
using current web scale programming and
system technologies
but um first of all I agree with drug on
I second that but to go back to the
point about api's and we see a hundred
percent of people you know agree we
should be doing this I think with
funders a big part of the problem is
they expect us to have everything
figured out going into the the grant you
know and it doesn't happen that way we
know that you know needs arise you see
how the potential of something there are
people out here here today that can help
us do those things there needs to be
more nimble funding there needs to be
some repositories of money where you can
make a quick pitch or quick explanation
why you need this why you want to try it
a little bit of you know support from
the community to say yes and and
repositories of people to do it so I
think you know we have to kind of press
for new new models of a funding sure but
I think also what were what we're trying
to do with with this I'll be a
complicated picture is to facilitate
that more nimble experimentation that
you were that you're talking about
because if if you could freely enter
intermix all these different components
you you can tinker around around the
edges you don't have to you don't have
to be touching the entire full
monolithic system so that's certainly
something that we the CDL are very much
interested in this kind of approach for
exactly that reason we're actually
shifting from running our own
infrastructure over to the use of
archived it to address many of the
concerns that we talked about you know
at the beginning of the presentation and
we're doing that precisely because we
think that will allow us to reallocate
our limited local resources to two
highly added value systems
you know alternative enhanced enhance
discovery alternative capture and
exactly those types of things where will
then be able to plug in the results of
that work into you know commodity
solution yes in addressing the
organizational side so that that third
part of the of the grant two weeks ago
Catherine scanner gave a great keynote
out at archiving that was speaking
specifically about you know when we
think about collaborations often it is
sort of you know that's assumed to be
large players and small players when we
aren't at that table in part the whole
point she was making was but we need to
figure out is what do people have to
offer and then bring those people in
whether they're from a large
organization that has no money from a
small organization that has a lot of
funding and a lot of technical expertise
or somewhere that can actually provide
other sort of organizational or content
depth to it and so speaking to the point
that was raised earlier you know if
you're a small organization how can you
how can you participate I think exactly
looking at what our collaborated not
models that we're building and making
sure that people can in fact participate
so we have that diversity of the voices
at the table yes so smaller institutions
have a real challenge in this debate I
think that's pretty clear it isn't it
the case that the API models that you're
putting up there would allow smaller
software packages that allowed sort of
downloading and preserving websites to
be plugged in to other systems that
could then preserve them and provide
access to them so it could enable a more
diverse approach to web archiving at the
lower level as well yes that's that's
the supposition that we're moving ahead
on yes
but yeah I I agree but I think Stephen
brought up something that worrying me
and the Abby Smith rumsey stressed in
her talk at the IPC GA which is so
you're saying you want to concentrate on
high value-added activities for your
community those high added value
activities are almost all concerned with
access and not with actually collecting
the stuff what looks like to me is that
what everybody wants is for the Internet
Archive to collect everything and though
people would grab pieces of it and build
customized delivery systems on top of it
and the difficulty with that is what I
be was pointing out is that this is
building a monoculture situation and
this is defining what is archived able
as what the internet archive can get
their hands on and that's a very
dangerous path to be going down and that
what we really need here is precisely
the ability to plug in to the entire
infrastructure not into our private
infrastructure multiple different
collection technologies and part of what
is needed in re-engineering our our
collection tools is the kind of approach
that I na developed where they because
of the diversity of the audiovisual
sites that they were collecting they had
to develop an architecture with many
different customized collection tools
coexisting behind in in one piece of
architecture and that involves defining
things like the collection proxy that
actually collects stuff and the
management tools the target the
collectors and allow them to decide for
example that oh I found something on
this site that leads this other
collector to go collect it and
it's that kind of plug and play
infrastructure for collection is very
important in avoiding the idea that the
only stuff we can preserve is stuff that
era tricks can get its hands on well
we're we're we're certainly interested
in added value discovery but we're also
very much interested in added value
capture we're very happy to to let
archive it be responsible for you know
the routine capture the heretics base
capture but we know that that is missing
a lot of stuff that our curators are
interested in so having the ability to
have alternative capture mechanisms that
could then be injected into our common
archiving collections is something
that's seems to be a very important
aspect for us so this i think the slides
will be available so you'll be able to
see the picture better because it's
really hard to see i know so near the
top it has a module that's for
alternative capture because you know in
our case we have content that can't we
have web archive content or websites
that have been given to us that we can't
integrate with the west rest because
they're in a completely different format
and you probably have cases it with that
same way people don't give you arcs or
works right I mean that's not what they
have they have other you know content
and other formats so we definitely need
a variety of different ways to collect
this content but the thing about this
this model is it uses on the left and
the right it's actually using the same
exact api's so it's saying that we what
we should work towards is having our
tools speak the same interfaces so that
we can plug and play so that we can have
the opportunity to do alternative
captures etc and so a lot of times when
we talk about this we do focus on the
access side because that is the side
that you know does lead to new research
and has the biggest bang for your buck
but there's definitely interest
I know within my institution in the
preservation side as well in the
alternative capture as well a slightly
different topic of great concern and
that is you know one of the chief
barriers to use of web archives is the
creation of disparate different web
archives in different places and to tell
our researchers oh go to these seven
places and maybe you'll find some useful
content and try to merge them and try to
do something with them think it's a big
challenge but we have to address this
question of discovery and and the user
experience that we're trying to create
for historians and other users of this
content and Internet Archive has a great
value in that respect for being a
consolidating place that people can do
single searches but I'm interested in
whether the modeling that you've talked
about would help to address the broader
discovery question as well it certainly
could I mean there's a there's a box for
that and I know that well I don't speak
for Jefferson but the internet hive is
it certainly is interested in this they
participated very fully in this effort
as a matter of fact you know there's
actually a subset of the institutions
that were involved on that failed I am
less proposal that have just put in a
new proposal more tightly scoped
addressing some of the concerns that
came back that the reviewers notes on
the original one so
archive it is going to be moving ahead
with the development of you know not not
this comprehensive set of api's but
they're going to is a test case they'll
be moving forward with I think an export
API with the idea that you know if that
proves to be beneficial that they could
then move on to exposing other aspects
of private function
oh thank you and the the point of that
is you know if you look at your program
you'll notice it says closing
discussions or we're supposed to start a
little while ago and the reception it's
not supposed to start yet you're all
sitting there thinking my god we've been
here all day when are they going to let
us go and drink and there were two
reasons why we scheduled the closing
discussions as we did one is that we
plan to end before the food arrived I'm
happy to say that probably is no longer
true but the other one is that you know
we the last the last maybe 15 minutes
have kind of morphed from what we expect
Lee as we expected into discussion as
opposed to just a bunch of questions
that's trivializing questions but anyway
what we did want I throughout the day
you've been hearing some occasionally
references to tomorrow I just wanted to
provide a little bit explanation there
when we first started to plan this
meeting we thought what we're asking all
of these you know these speakers and
these researchers who have done all this
work and involved in these
collaborations to come here as long as
they're going to be here in travel
assistance let's carve out some time on
the next day for them to have just some
focused discussions around some of these
issues and then as that started to
develop started that they see the value
of more people get any added and so
forth the problem is we we have a
limited amount of space tomorrow so we
had to cut off that and not everyone
will have an opportunity to take part in
those discussions I really regret that
because there's been so much good
discussion here but that also means we
definitely wanted to provide an
opportunity now for for some of that
discussion to take place for anyone here
to be able to say you know give some
reactions to things they've heard ask
some further questions of the audience
or anyone in particular I won't make you
stay here longer than you want to but I
still want to make that opportunity
available what I will say so that I
don't have to repeat it again so that
you're aware of it the reception that
will take place is on the sixth floor of
this building just take the elevator
down to six and it's on the opposite
side there's
cafe and a terrace and wine and food and
so forth so Mike is open are there
people want to say something or ask
something
over here
out of the scope of this discussion
Andrea alluded to it in our organization
we need to capture websites that are not
necessarily going to be readily
available to the public their internal
websites they're usually for legal or
eventually for archival purposes I work
at a university archives and I was
wondering if anybody has any comments on
that we run into issues with things like
pin protection or just plain not being
able to provide access the way people
imagine you would in a traditional
library setting I'm sure there are
people here at could speak to that I
know we all have all I want many of us
have similar situations I think most of
us have a mixture of what can be made
public and what cannot and various ways
of trying to control that and how do we
get a mic to Abby
hi excuse me I have a brief announcement
Mike OPI dr. Edward for Fox had secured
a special issue on web archiving on
international journal digital libraries
and we will put out couple papers very
soon and please stay tuned and you're
all welcome to participate thanks a lot
I can cover the on-site of site access
issue at the Library of Congress we even
though the copyright office is in our
building that makes it worse for us
because we have to follow very strict
rules unfortunately so we have a lot of
content that we haven't received
off-site access permissions for and that
is restricted to onsite only we can
provide the metadata but not the capture
so we are struggling with this and we
don't think there are a whole lot of
users coming into the reading rooms and
using those we're pretty sure there
aren't I just started to get some web
metrics about that because there are
some terminals that are tracking that so
it'll be interesting to see if anybody
finds our web archives that way we've
done other things like ship data you
know that still here but we have shipped
data to researchers outside of the
library which is an interesting use case
and we can do that again but it's a lot
of work but it's a struggle to try to
figure out how people might use archive
zhan site or even know that we have them
so like the BNF you have to go to the
library in Paris to access the archives
there and they have little terminals and
say access the web archive here but how
many people actually do that who knows
and archive it has restricted access
functionality so there's lots of people
that collect via arc of it that do not
make it public and can either provide
local
via marks are restricted IP range
i think brian at the microphone yeah so
i wanted to touch on something that i
don't think i've heard anyone talk about
sort of the opposite of archiving that
may fall under the right to be forgotten
there's something timely in the news
just I think yesterday Twitter decided
to shut down the sunlight foundation's
pollen tubes or something I don't know
how they say it but they archive the
tweets of politicians even when they say
something embarrassing and later deleted
and they Twitter took the position right
that you know even politicians ought to
be allowed to make mistakes and and
delete something and we're going to cut
off your API access because of what
you're doing we have a problem like this
that we experience every day I get angry
emails from litigants who are like why
are you violating my privacy by putting
my court case online and I i have to say
we've come up with methods for dealing
with that mainly what we and I've given
whole talks about it but the short
version is if you get people out of
Google they're satisfied right they
don't think they don't really care if
their stuff stays on my site so long as
googling their name doesn't bring up
their document but anyway if people are
interested in these kinds of issues we
have spent a lot of time thinking about
them and would enjoy talking about it
over drinks ok so I'll address the
collection of restricted sites problem
because this is something we do all the
time because we collect subscription
academic journals and so we have to deal
with login pages we have to deal with in
some cases we have a specific user agent
that the the site recognizes as being
yeah it's ok you don't know need to ask
these guys to login we can do it with
over HTTPS with a certificate check at
both ends there are a number of
techniques for doing this i mean if if
you control the crow
and the website the easiest way is to
tell the website what they well the IP
address of the cross and that that will
fix the problem in a very simple way but
yes it's a it's a pain if if you really
if you really need to do this in in with
only marginally cooperative websites we
have some advice quick scan
okay i'm going to end just by thanking
again the people who put this together
particularly Alex Thurmond and a parigi
and our wonderful my campers here have
been with us all day taking care of
things and thank all of you for coming
and the mellon Foundation for making all
this possible thank you very much